هيا هيا في الملعب هيا لا تَهْدئي لا تَتَعبي لا لا لا لا
في الملعبِ هيا ثِبي لا تَهْدئي لا تَتَعبي
ومِن قَدَم إلى قَدَم مثلَ ارتعاشاتِ النَّغَم
يُحِبها الكبارُ والصِّغار كأنَّها عُصفورةٌ من نار
حياتُها في الأرضِ والفضاء   أنشودةٌ مسحورةُ الغِناء
تَرتاحُ في الميدان أَقل من ثَوان تَرتاحُ  أقل من ثوان
وفَجأَةٌ تَطير عُصفورةُ الأَثيرْ تَطير عُصفورةُ الأَثيرْ
ومِن قَدَم إلى قَدَم حتَّى يُصفِّرَ الحَكَمْ
هيا هيا في الملعب هيا لا تَهْدئي لا تَتَعبي لا لا لا لا
يا حُلوَة الأَلوانِ في يَدي يا حُلوَة الأَلوانِ في يَدي
إذا انتهى دَرْسي ومَعْهدي إذا انتهى دَرْسي ومَعْهدي
قَفَزْتُ مِثْلَ السَّهمِ في الطَّريق قَفَزْتُ مِثْلَ السَّهمِ في الطَّريق
بَحَثْتُ في الزُقاقِ عَنْ رَفيقْ بَحَثْتُ في الزُقاقِ عَنْ رَفيقْ
ومِن قَدَم إلى قَدَم تُرَفْرِفِينَ كَالنَّغَمْ
هيا هيا في الملعب هيا لا تَهْدئي لا تَتَعبي لا لا لا لا
في الملعبِ هيا ثِبي لا تَهْدئي لا تَتَعبي
ومِن قَدَم إلى قَدَم مثلَ ارتعاشاتِ النَّغَم